The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I hoped I might have
Exam 2 for you today,
but it's not quite
back from the grader.
It's already gone to the second
grader, so it will not be long.
And I hope you've had a
look at the MATLAB homework
for a variety of possible--
I think we've got,
there were some errors in
the original statement,
location of the coordinates,
but I think they're fixed now.
So ready to go on that MATLAB.
Don't forget that it's four
on the right-hand side and not
one, so if you get
an answer near 1/4
at the center of the
circle, that's the reason.
Just that factor
four is to remember.
I'll talk more about the
MATLAB this afternoon
in the review
session right here.
Just to say, I'm highly
interested in that problem.
Not just increasing
N, the number
of mesh points in
the octagon, but also
increasing the number of sides.
So there are two numbers there,
we had N points on a ray,
out from the center.
But we have M sides
of the polygon.
And I'm interested in both
of those, getting big.
Growing.
I don't know how.
And maybe a reasonable
balance is to take,
I think N proportional to
M is a pretty good balance.
So I'd be very happy;
I mean I'm very
happy with whatever you do.
But I'm really interested
to know what happens
as both of these increase.
How close, how quickly
do you approach
the eigenvalues of a circle.
And you might keep
the two proportional
as you increase them.
So let me say more about that
this afternoon, because it's
a big day today,
to start Fourier.
Fourier series, the new
chapter, the new topic.
In fact, the final major
topic of the course.
So I tried to list here,
so here I'm in Section 4.1,
so I'm talking about
Fourier series.
So Fourier series is for
functions that have period 2pi.
It involves things like sin(x),
like cos(x), like e^(ikx),
all of those if I increase x by
2pi, I'm back where I started.
So that's the sort of functions
that have Fourier series.
Then we'll go on to the other
two big forms, crucial forms
of the Fourier world.
But 4.1 starts with the
classical Fourier series.
So I realize you will
have seen, many of you
will have seen
Fourier series before.
I hope you'll see
some new aspects here.
So, let me just get organized.
It's nice to have some examples
that just involve sine.
And since the sine is
an odd function, that
means it's sort of
anti-symmetric across zero,
those are the functions that
will have only sine, that
will have a sine expansion.
Cosines are the opposite.
Cosines are symmetric
across zero.
Like a constant, or like cos(x).
Zero comes right at
the symmetric point.
So those will have only cosines.
And a lot of examples fit in
one or the other of those,
and it's easy to see them.
The general function, of course,
is a combination odd and even.
It has cosines and
it has sines, it's
just the sum of the two pieces.
So, this is the
standard Fourier series,
which I couldn't
get onto one line,
but it has all the
cosines including
this slightly different
cos(0), and all the sines.
But because this one has
these three different pieces,
the constant term, the other
cosines, all the sines,
three slightly
different formulas,
it's actually nicest of
all, to use this final form.
Because there's
just one formula.
There's just one kind.
And I'll call its
coefficient c_k,
and now they multiply e^(ikx),
so we have to get used
to e^(ikx).
We may be more familiar
with sin(kx) and cos(kx),
but everybody knows e^(ikx)
is a combination of them.
And if we let k go from
minus infinity to infinity,
so we've got all the
terms, including e^(-i3x),
and e^(+i3x), those would
combine to give cosines
and sines of 3x.
We get one nice formula.
There's just one
formula for the c's.
So that's one good reason
to look at the complex form.
Even if our function
is actually real.
That form is kind of neat,
and the second good reason,
the really important
reason, is then
when we go to the discrete
Fourier transform,
the DFT, everybody writes
that with complex numbers.
So it's good to see
complex numbers first
and then we can just
translate the formulas from--
And these are also almost always
written with complex numbers.
So this is the way to see it.
OK, so what do we do
about Fourier series?
What do we have
to know how to do
and what should we understand?
Well, if you've
met Fourier series
you may have met the formula
for these coefficients.
That's sort of like step one.
If I'm given the function,
whatever the function might be,
might be a delta function.
Interesting case, always.
Always interesting.
Always crazy right?
But it's always interesting,
the delta function.
The coefficients
can be computed.
The coefficients, you'll see,
I'll repeat those formulas.
They involve integrals.
What I want to say
right now is that this
isn't a course in integration.
So I'm not interested in doing
more and more complicated
integrals and finding
Fourier coefficients
of weird functions.
No way.
I want to understand
the simple, straight,
the important examples.
And here's a point that's
highly interesting.
In practice, in
computing practice,
we're close to
computing practice here.
In everything we do.
I mean, this is really
constantly used.
And one important question is,
is the Fourier series quickly
convergent?
Because if we're
going to compute,
we don't want to compute
a thousand terms.
Hopefully ten terms, 20 terms
would give us good accuracy.
So that question comes down
to how quickly does those a's
and b's and c's go to zero?
That's highly important.
And you'll connect
this decay rate,
we'll connect this with the
smoothness of the function.
Oh, I can tell you
even at a start.
OK, so I just want to
emphasize this point.
We'll see it over and over
that like for a delta function,
which is not smooth at all,
we'll see no decay at all.
In the coefficients.
They're constant.
They don't decrease as we go to
higher and higher frequencies.
I think of k here, I'll use
the word frequency for k.
So high frequency means high
k, far up the Fourier series,
and the question is, are
the coefficients staying up
there big, and we have
to worry about them?
Or do they get very small?
So a delta function is
a key example and then
a step function.
So what will be the
deal with those?
If I have a function
that's a step function,
I'll have decay at rate is 1/k..
So they do go to zero.
The thousandth coefficient
will be roughly of size 1/1000.
That's not fast.
That's not really fast
enough to compute with.
Well, we meet step functions,
I mean, functions with jumps.
And we'll see that their
Fourier series, the coefficients
do go to zero but not very fast.
And we get something
highly interesting.
So when we do these
examples, so I've
sort of moved on to examples,
so these are two basic examples.
What would be the next example?
Step function.
Well, yeah, or maybe a hat next.
A hat function would be, you
see what I'm doing at each step?
I'm integrating.
A hat function might be the
next, yeah, a ramp, exactly.
Hat function, which is
a ramp with a corner.
Now, so that's one
integral better.
You want to guess the decay
rate on that one? k squared.
Now we're getting better.
That's a faster follow-up.
One over k squared.
And then we integrate again,
we'd get one over k cubed.
Then one more integral,
one over k fourth
would be a cubic spline.
You remember the cubic
spline is continuous.
Its derivative is
continuous, that
gives us a one over k cubed.
Its second derivative
is continuous,
that gives us a one
over k to the fourth,
and then you really
can compute with that,
if you have such a function.
So, point: pay
attention to decay rate.
That, and the connection
to smoothness.
So examples, we'll start
right off with these guys.
And then we'll see the
rules for the derivative.
Oh yeah, rules for
the derivative.
The beauty of Fourier series
is, well, actually you
can see this.
You can see the rule.
Let me just show you
the rule for this.
So the rule for derivatives,
the whole point about Fourier
is, it connects
perfectly with calculus.
With taking derivatives.
So suppose I have F(x)
equals, I'll use this form,
the sum of c_k e^(ikx).
And now I take its derivative.
dF/dx.
What do you think is the
derivative, what's the Fourier
series for the derivative?
Suppose I have the Fourier
series for some function,
and then I take Fourier
series for the derivative.
So I'm kind of going
the backwards way.
Less smooth.
I'm going from, the derivative
of the step function
involves delta functions,
so I'm going less smooth
as I take derivatives.
It's so easy, it jumps at you.
What's the rule?
Just take the derivative
of every term,
so I'll have the sum
of, now what happens
when I take the derivative?
Everybody see what
happens when I
take the derivative of that
typical term in the Fourier
series?
What happens?
The derivative brings
down a factor ik.
With k being the thing that--
So it's ik times what we have.
So these are the Fourier
coefficients of the derivative.
And that again makes exactly the
same point about the decay rate
or the opposite,
the non-decay rate.
As I take the derivative you
got a rougher function, right?
Derivative of a step function
is a delta, derivative of a hat
would have some steps.
We're going less smooth as
we take more derivatives.
And every time we
do it, we see, you
understand the decay rate now?
Because the derivative
just brings a factor ik,
so its high frequencies
are more present.
Have larger coefficients.
So and of course,
the second derivative
would bring down ik squared.
So that our equations,
for example,
let me just do an
application here.
Without pushing it.
Our application, we started
this course with equations like
-u''(x) = delta(x-a).
Right?
If we wanted to apply to
a differential equation,
how would I do it?
I would take the Fourier
series of both sides.
I would look at, I'd jump
into what people would
call the frequency domain.
So this is a differential
equation written as usual
in the physical domain.
And with physical
variable x, position.
Or it could be time.
And now let me take
Fourier transforms.
So what would happen here?
If I take the Fourier
transform of this,
well, we'll soon see, right?
We get Fourier
coefficients of the deltas.
Of the delta function.
That's a key example,
and you see why.
Over here, what will we get?
And now I'm taking
two derivatives,
so I bring down ik twice.
So I'm looking.
Here it would be
the sum of whatever
the delta's coefficients are.
Shall we call those d?
The alphabet's coming
out right. d for delta.
So the right side has
coefficients, d_k.
And what about the left side?
What are the coefficients--
If the solution
u has coefficients c_k,
so let's call this u now.
Has coefficients c_k,
then what happens
to the second
derivative? ik, ik again,
that's i squared k
squared, the minus sign.
So we would have the sum
of k squared c_k e^(ikx).
This is if u itself has
coefficient c_k, then -u'' has
these coefficients.
So what's up?
How would we use that?
It's going to be easy.
We'll just match terms.
Right?
I can see, what's my
formula, what should c_k
be if I know the d_k?
I'm given the right-hand side.
We're just doing what's
constantly happening,
this three step process.
You're given the right side.
Step one, expand it
in Fourier series now.
Step two, match the two sides.
So what's the formula for c_k?
In this application,
which, by the way
I had no intention to do this.
But it jumped into my head and
I thought why not just do it.
What would be the
formula for c_k?
It'll be d_k divided
by? k squared.
You're just matching terms.
Just the way, when we expanded
things in eigenvectors,
we'd match the coefficients
of the eigenvectors,
and that involved
just the simple step,
here it's d_k over k squared.
Good.
And then what's the final step?
The final step is, now you
know the right coefficients,
add them back up.
Add the thing back
up, like here,
only I'm temporarily calling
it u, to find the solution.
Right?
Three steps.
Go into the frequency domain.
Write the right-hand
side as a Fourier series.
Second quick step is
look at the equation
for each separate
Fourier coefficient.
Match the coefficients
of these eigenvectors.
Eigenfunctions.
And that's this
quick middle step.
And then you've got the
answer, but you're still
in Fourier space, you're
still in frequency space.
So you have to use
these, put them back
to get the answer
in physical space.
Right?
That's the pattern.
Over and over.
So that's sort of the general
plan of applying Fourier.
And when does it work?
When does it work?
Because, I mean it's
fantastic when it works.
So what is it about this
problem that made it work?
When is Fourier happy?
You know, when does
he raise his hand,
say yes I can
solve that problem?
OK, what do I need here
for this plan to work?
I certainly don't need always
just -u'', Fourier could do
better than that.
But what's the requirement
for Fourier to work perfectly?
Well, linear equation, right?
If we didn't have
linear equations
we couldn't do all this
adding and matching and stuff.
So linear equations.
Well, OK.
Now, what other
linear equations?
Could I have a c(x) in here?
My familiar c(x),
variable material property
inside this equation?
No.
Well, not easily, anyway.
That would really mess
things up if there's
a variable coefficient
in here then
it's going to have its
own Fourier series.
We're going to be
multiplying Fourier series.
That comes later and
it's not so clean.
So we want, it
works perfectly when
it's constant coefficients.
Constant coefficients in
the differential equations.
And then one more thing.
Very important other thing.
The boundary conditions.
Everybody remembers
now, it's a part
of the message of this course
is that boundary conditions are
often a source of trouble.
They're part of the problem,
you have to deal with them.
Now, what boundary conditions
do we think about here?
Well, fixed-fixed
was where we started.
So if we had fixed-fixed
boundary conditions what would
I expect?
Then things would give me
a sine series, possibly.
Because those are the
eigenfunctions we're used to.
Fixed-fixed, it's sines that
go from zero back to zero.
Fixed-free will have
some sines or cosines.
Periodic would be
the best of all.
Yeah, so we need nice
boundary conditions.
So the boundary conditions,
let me just say,
periodic would be great.
Or sometimes fixed-free.
Our familiar ones, at
least in simple cases,
can be dealt with.
OK.
So now, boy, that board is
already full of formulas.
But, let's go back to
the start and say how
do we find the coefficients?
So because that
was the first step.
Take the right-hand side,
find its coefficient.
If we want to, just as
applying eigenvalues,
the first step is
always find eigenvalues.
Here, in applying
Fourier, the first step
is always find the coefficients.
So, how do we do that?
And at the beginning it
doesn't look too easy, right?
Because let me take
the first guy, sin(x).
Let me take an example.
A particular S(x).
The most important,
interesting function.
S(x), I want it to
be an odd function,
so that it will have only sines.
And it should have period 2pi.
So let me just graph it.
So it's going to
have coefficients,
and I use b for sine, so it's
going to have b_1*sin(x),
and b_2*sin(2x), and so on.
And so it's got a whole
infinity of coefficients.
Right?
We're in function space.
We're not dealing
with vectors now.
So how is it possible to
find those coefficients?
And let me chose
a particular S(x).
So I'll put, since
it's 2pi periodic,
if I tell you what it
is over a 2pi interval,
just repeat, repeat, repeat.
So I'll pick the 2pi interval
to be minus pi to pi here.
Just because it's a nice way,
and so that's a 2pi length.
There's zero, I want to
function to be odd across zero.
And I want it to be
simple, because it's
going to be an important example
that I can actually compute.
So I'm going to make it a one.
And a minus one there.
So, a step function.
A step function, a square--
And if I repeat it, of course,
it would go down,
up, down, up, so on.
But we only have to
look over this part.
OK.
Now, well, you might
say wait a minute
how are we going to expand
this function in sines.
Well, sines are odd functions.
Everybody knows what odd means?
Odd means that S(-x) is -S(x).
So that's the anti-symmetric
that we see in that graph.
We also see a few
problems in this graph.
At x=0, what is our sine
series going to give us?
If I plug in x=0 on the
right-hand side I get zero,
certainly.
So this sine series
is going to do that.
And actually Fourier
series tend to do this.
In the middle of
a jump it'll pick
the middle point of a jump.
Fourier series generally,
it's the best possible,
will pick the middle
point of the jump.
And what about at x=pi?
At the end of the interval?
What does my series
add up at x=pi?
Zero again, because
sin(pi), sin(2pi), all zero.
And that'll be in the
middle of that jump.
So it's pretty good.
But now what I'm hoping
is that my sine series
is going to somehow get
real fast up to one,
and level out at one.
We're asking a lot.
In fact, when Fourier proposed
this idea, Fourier series,
there was a lot of doubters.
Was it really possible to
represent other functions,
maybe even including
a step function,
in terms of sines
or maybe cosines?
And Fourier said
yes, go with it.
So let's do it.
OK, so and he turned out
to be incredibly right.
How do I find b_2?
Do you remember how to-- I
don't want to know the formula.
I want to know why.
What's the step to find
the coefficient b_2?
Well, the step
is-- The key point.
Which makes everything possible.
Why don't I identify
the key point
without which we would
be in real trouble.
The key point is that
all these sine functions,
sin(2x), sin(3x),
sin(4x), are orthogonal.
Now, what do I mean by two
functions being orthogonal?
Somehow my picture
in function space,
so my picture in
function space is
that here is, this is
the sine x coordinate.
And somewhere there's a sin(2x)
coordinate and it's 90 degrees
and then there's a
sin(3x) coordinate,
and then there's a sine, I
don't know where to point now.
But there is a sin(4x),
we're in infinite dimensions.
And the sine vectors
are an orthogonal basis.
They're orthogonal
to each other.
What does that mean?
Vectors, we take
the dot product.
Functions, we take, we don't
use the word dot product as much
as inner product.
So let me take the inner
product of-- The whole point
is orthogonality.
Let me write that word down.
Orthogonal.
The sines are orthogonal.
And what does that mean?
That means that the integral
over our 2pi interval,
or any 2pi interval,
of one sine, sin(kx),
let's say, multiplied by
another sine, sin(lx),
dx is, you can guess the answer.
And everything is
depending on this answer.
And it is?
Zero.
It's just terrific.
If k is different
from l, of course.
If k is equal to l then I
have to figure that one out.
I'll need that one.
What is it if sine, if k=l so
I'm integrating sine squared
of kx, then it's
certainly not zero.
I getting like,
the length squared
of the sin(kx) function.
If k=l, what is it?
It has some nice formula.
Very nice.
Let's see.
Sine squared, do I need to
think about sine squared kx?
Sine squared kx,
what does it do?
Well, just graph sine squared x.
What would the graph
of sine squared x
look like, from minus pi to pi?
So it goes up, right?
Doesn't it go up?
And then it goes back down.
OK.
Sorry, I made that
a little hard.
Is that right?
And then it keeps it up.
Right.
So, what's the integral of that?
I'm not seeing quite why.
The answer is its
average value is 1/2.
The integral of sine squared
is half of the length.
The whole interval
is of length 2pi,
and we're taking the
area under sine squared.
I may have to come back
to it, but the answer
would be half of
2pi, which is pi.
Yeah, yeah.
So you could say the
length of the sine function
is square root of pi.
So these are integrals.
You told me the answer was zero.
And I agreed with you, but
we haven't computed it.
And nor have we really got that.
So a little bit to fix, still.
But the crucial
fact, I mean, those
are highly important integrals
that just come out beautifully.
And beautifully
really means zero.
I mean, that's the beautiful
number, right, for an integral.
OK, so now how do I use that?
Again, I'm looking for b_2.
How do I pick off
b_2, using the fact
that sin(2x) times any other
sine integrates to zero.
Ready for the moment?
To find the coefficient b_2?
I should, let me start this
sentence and if you finish it.
I'll multiply both sides of
this equation by sin(2x).
And then I will integrate.
I'll multiply both
sides by sin(2x),
so I take S(x) sin(2x).
And on the right hand, I
have b_1 sin(x) sin(2x).
And then I have
b_2-- Now, here's
the one that's going to live
through the integration.
It's going to survive, because
it's the sin(2x) times sin(2x),
sin(2x) squared.
And then comes the b_3 guy,
would be b_3 sin(3x) sin(2x).
Everybody sees what I'm doing?
As we did with the weak form
in differential equations,
I'm multiplying
through by these guys.
And then I'm integrating
over the interval.
And what do I get?
Integrate everyone dx.
And what's the result?
What is that integral?
Zero.
It's gone.
What is this
integral, the integral
of sin(3x) times sin(2x)?
Zero.
All those sines
integrate to zero,
and I have to come back and
see it's a simple trig identity
to do it.
To see why that's zero.
Do you see that everything
is disappearing, except b_2.
So we finally have the
formula that we want.
Let me just with put
these formulas down.
So b_k, b_2 or b_k, yeah
tell me the formula for b_k.
Let me go back, here.
What did b_2 come out to be?
So I have b_2, that's a number.
It's got this right-hand side.
That's the integral
that I mentioned.
You'd have to compute
that integral.
And then what about this stuff?
This sin(2x) squared?
I've integrated that.
And what did I get for that?
This is b_2, and then
this is some number.
And it's pi.
So this is b_2, and
multiplying, right?
That b_2 comes out,
and then I have
the integral of sine squared
2x, and that's what's pi.
So that's b_2 times pi here,
and I just divide by the pi.
So I divide by pi and
I get the integral
from minus pi to pi of my
function times my sine.
That's the model for
all the coefficients
of orthogonal series.
That's the model.
Cosines, the complete ones,
the complex coefficients.
The Legendre series,
the Bessel series,
everybody's series will
follow this same model.
Because all those series are
series of orthogonal functions.
Everything is hinging
on this orthogonality.
The fact that one term
times another gives zero.
What that means, really.
I want to say it
with a picture, too.
So let me draw two
orthogonal directions.
I intentionally didn't make
them just x and y axes.
This might be the
direction of sin(x),
and this might be the
direction of sin(2x).
And then I have a function.
And I'm trying to find
out how much of sin(2x)
has it got in it?
How much of sin(x)
has it got in it,
and then of course there's also
a sin(3x) and all the other
sin(kx)'s.
The point is, the point
of this 90 degree angle
there is, that I can split this
S(x), whatever it might be,
I can find its sin(x)
piece directly.
By just projecting it,
it's the projection
of my function on
that coordinate.
If you don't like
sin(x), sin(2x), S(x),
write v_1, v_2, whatever.
To think of it as vectors.
What's the sin two--
So that is b_1*sin(x).
That's the right
amount of sin(x).
And the whole point is that that
calculation didn't involve b_2
and b_3 and all the other b's.
When I'm projecting onto
orthogonal directions,
I can do them one at a time.
I can do one one-dimensional
projection at a time.
This b_k*sin(kx) is the, so
I'm just saying this in words,
is the projection of my
function onto sin(kx).
And the point is, I
could do this and get
this answer because of
that 90 degree angle.
If I didn't have
90 degrees, do you
see that this wouldn't work?
Suppose my two basis functions
are at some 40 degree angle.
Then I take my function.
Can I project that
onto this guy?
And project that onto this guy,
so the projections are there?
And there?
Do they add back to the
function that I started with?
The given function?
No way.
I mean, these are
much too big, right?
If I add that one to this one
I'm way out here somewhere.
But over here, with
90 degrees, these
are the two projections,
project there.
Project there.
Add those two pieces
and I got back exactly.
I just want to emphasize the
importance of orthogonality.
It breaks the problem down into
one-dimensional projections.
So here we go with b_k*sin(kx).
OK, let me do the
key example now.
This example.
Let me find the coefficients of
that particular function S(x).
This is the step function,
the square wave, S(x),
let's find its coefficients.
I'll just use this formula.
OK, maybe I'll erase so that
I can write the integration
right underneath.
OK.
Oh, one little point here.
Well, not so little,
but it's a saving.
It's worth noticing.
The reward for picking
off the odd function
is, I think that this integral
is the same from minus
pi to zero as zero to pi.
In other words, I think
that for an odd function,
I get the same answer if I
just do the integral from zero
to pi, that I have to do.
And double it.
So I think if I
just double it, I
don't know if you
regard that as a saving.
In some way, the work
is only half as much.
It'll make this
particular example easy,
so let me do this example.
What are the
Fourier coefficients
of the square wave?
OK, so I'll do this integral.
So from zero to pi,
what is my function?
My N from the graph?
Just one.
This is going to
be a picnic, right?
The function is one here.
So S(x) is one, so I want 2/pi,
the integral from zero to pi
of just sin(kx) dx, right?
Which is, so I've got 2/pi,
now I integrate sin(kx),
I get minus cos(kx), right?
Between zero and pi.
And what else?
What have I forgotten?
The most important point.
The integral of sin(kx)
is not minus cos(kx).
I have to divide by k.
It's the division by k
that's going to give me
the correct decay rate.
2/(pi*k).
Alright, now I've got a
little calculation to do.
I have to figure out what is
cos(kx) at zero, no problem,
it's one.
And at the other point, at x=pi.
So what am I getting, then?
I'm getting 2/pi-- no, 2/(pi*k).
With that minus sign,
I'll evaluate it at x=0,
I have one minus whatever
I get at the top.
cos(k*pi).
That's b_k.
So there's a typical, well not
typical but very nice, answer.
Now let's see what
these numbers are.
So let me take a 2/pi out here.
And then just list
these numbers.
So k is one, two, three,
four, five, right?
Tell me what these
numbers are for-- Let me
put the k in here because
that's part of it.
So it's a constant, 2/pi.
At k=1, what do I get?
At k=1?
This is the little bit
that needs the patience.
At k=1, the cosine of pi is?
Negative one.
So I have net minus
minus one, I get a two.
I get a two over
a one. k is one.
Alright, that is the
coefficient for k=1.
Now, what's b_2, the
coefficient for k=2?
I have 1-cos(2pi),
what's cos(2pi)?
One.
So they cancel, so I get a zero.
There is no b_2.
What about b_3?
So now b_3, I have 1-cos(3pi).
What's the cosine of 3pi?
It's negative one again.
Right, same as the cosine of pi.
So that gives me a two, and
now I'm dividing by three.
2/3.
Alright, let's do two
more. k=4, what do I get?
Zero, because the cosine of
4pi has come back to one.
So I get a zero.
And what do I get from k=5?
1-cos(5pi), which is? cos(5pi)
is back to negative one,
so one minus negative
one is a two.
You see the pattern.
And so let me just copy the
famous series for this S(x).
This S(x) is, let's see.
The twos, I'll make
that 4/pi, right?
I'll take out all those twos.
So I have 4/pi 1-cos(5pi), I
have no sin(2x), forget that.
Now I do have some sin(3x)'s,
how much do I have?
4/pi sin(3x)'s.
But divide by three, right?
And then there's no
4x's, no sin(4x)'s.
But then there will be a 4/pi
sine, what's the next term now?
Are you with me?
So this is a typical nice
example, an important example.
Sine of what?
5x, divided by five.
OK.
That's a great example,
it's worth remembering.
Factor the 4/pi
out if you want to.
4/pi times sin(x),
sine(3x)/3, sin(5x)/5,
it's a beautiful example
of an odd function.
OK, and let's see.
So what do you think,
MATLAB can draw this graph
far better than we can.
But let me draw
enough so you see
what's really interesting here.
Interesting and famous.
So the leading term
is 4/pi sin(x), that
would be something like that.
That's as close
as sin(x) can get,
4/pi is the optimal number.
The optimal coefficient.
The projection.
This 4/pi*sin(x) is the best,
the closest I can get to one.
On that interval.
With just sin(x).
But now when I put
in sin(3x), I think
it'll do something
more like this.
Do you see what's
happening there?
That's what I've got with
sin(3x), and of course
odd on the other side.
What do you think it
looks like with sin(5x)?
It's just so great you have
to let the computer draw
it a couple of times.
You see, it goes up here.
And then it's sort of, you
know, it's getting closer.
It's going to stay
closer to that.
But I don't know if you
can see from my picture,
I'm actually proud
of that picture.
It's not as bad as usual.
And it makes the crucial
point, two crucial points.
One is, I am going to get
closer and closer to one.
These oscillations, these
ripples, will be smaller.
But here is the
great fact and it's
a big headache in calculation.
At the jump, the first
ripple doesn't get smaller.
The first ripple gets thinner,
the first ripple gets thinner.
You see the ripples
moving over there,
but their height doesn't change.
Do you know whose name
is associated with that,
in that phenomenon?
Gibbs.
Gibbs noticed that the
ripple height as you
add more and more terms,
you're closer and closer
to the function over more
and more of the interval.
So the ripples get
squeezed to the left.
The area under the ripples
goes to zero, certainly.
But the height of
the ripples doesn't.
And it doesn't stay constant,
but nearly constant.
It approaches a famous number.
And of course we'll have the
same odd picture down here.
And it'll bump up
again, the same thing
is happening at every jump.
In other words, if
you're computing shock.
If you're computing
air flow around shocks,
with Fourier-type methods,
Gibbs is going to get you.
You'll have to deal with Gibbs.
Because the shock has
that extra ripple.
OK, that's a lot of Section 4.1.
Energy, we didn't
get to, so that'll
be the first point on Friday.
And I'll see you this afternoon
and talk about the MATLAB
or anything else.
OK.